jr what what is it about like you know
just your drive and like like like
obviously you've been the most
consistent through the crew just staying
with the with the [ __ ] being independent
building your
building your empire you know you're
involved in the cbd game doing a lot of
[ __ ]
um
but uh what what is it about like the
last decade or so of life that you've
like just doubled down on yourself and
having really you know some at the end
of the day man this rap [ __ ] has always
got to pay the bills it's always got to
make sense it's gotta you know what i
mean like it i'm sure it's easy to get
discouraged like why why did that no i
never get discouraged like even when i
was locked up i always was like
i love rap
i do this [ __ ] every day
so you know i mean this is you know this
is what i do plus i'm from harlem so i'm
a natural born hustler so whatever i
could get whatever rap allows me to get
next to and flourish that way then
that's what i do like as far as cbd or
whatever it is
there it is man and uh how many songs do
you guys have all together right now
like oh we got it we got it we got a lot
you got a whole album we did like we
just did like what four four records
since we've been here we already banned
i love la we doing we did we did some
records that i can't wait to people to
hear i'm they're guaranteed to say yo
this is what we miss
i'm telling you like when you if you're
fans of like
the spitters and you know
we're not just going to say just
dipstick fans just fans are spitters all
right
i think that's why everyone loved you
three